[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day we're
talking about a superintendent from New
Jersey who got caught pooping on a track
quit his job because he was so
embarrassed but now he's back in the
news because he's suing the police
department for $1,000,000 for
disseminating his mug shot Ainsley show
what that mug shot looks like whoa that
is the face of a man who would
Natacha when we were deciding what story
to talk about this was the only one that
you cared about
I mean pooping so funny too I just think
it's such a beautiful like layered story
because he has so much power you know I
mean a superintendent so he's in charge
of all the schools and yet he is the one
that we find has been taking a dump
I am someone who hopes to write for TV
truly is like a a story I want an option
one of the things that he's suing for is
loss of salary or future salary so that
the million dollar amount comes from the
fact that superintendents make a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a year I
think I did not realize oh yeah so this
was he had everything and he lost it for
a coup yeah I mean if he would have
brought the little doggie bag he's no
one would have cared just in public
school you're doing so yeah thank you
for asking
yeah I'm familiar with this for multiple
reasons as a runner sometimes in the
city you can't find a Starbucks you got
to go behind a dumpster you gotta find
you know a stoop wherever you also
earlier this year I hiked Mount Whitney
one of our national parks and you have
no carry out your poop because there's
too many people hiking on it so you poop
into a little thing called a
go back tie it up carry out your is it
hard to do that uh-huh great question so
are all right I didn't think we'd be
talking about 16 hours long
guess how many times I pooped in 16
hours 3 4 4 12 6 also you know I was
eating a bunch of goofs you know like
right now great question I carried with
me three bags did my companions
know so I had to borrow their bags like
white top okay why it's kind of like a
big plastic diaper
there's two layers to the bag the first
one has this little gel powder inside
supposed to help mask the odor I'm gonna
fold that one up there's like a ziploc
thing so you zip like that powder bag
tie that off so it helps to mask the
odor but I'll tell you what
why do you agree because what you guys
are not gonna like take a outdoors
at some point in your lives and like
what if your picture was like blown up
but every day every day he's the
superintendent he has keys go inside the
school go inside the school they have
keys to all the schools I don't think
there's one man somebody a letter
sure that he has the skeleton key to get
inside every single school is that
porta-potties on the track yeah they
usually do well so yeah it's just like
fine you poop on it once but his life is
ruined now
like I mean that's his life is ruined
because he's been and under the
bleachers of a school that's fine hope
he was what your life should be what
life should be right we're talking about
a music celeb now you mean that's the
ideal and make this back put this back
in the news this guy's off his rocker
you want to countersue him no for him to
sue the police right for where he's on
video again several times taking a
under the bleachers let him rest and get
a new job you are right that if the
thing he didn't want was his mug shot
out there I mean he's got to know that
if he's suing every article and YouTube
talk show he's gonna put up his much
debt where he lives like he's taking
another yeah 1:34 why he was doing
it because he's dating the girl at that
school or a woman I guess not good girl
this is school it's just someone from
that town correct yeah set it on fire
throw it at her door like be more like
aggressive I feel like at the
soil that's inner district you're
telling this man that doors to be more
aggressive yeah if that's what if he
wants to make impact on this woman's
life get the local schools I'm gonna do
sure that's like that happy gilmore
method right in the bag right on the the
doorstep so then he has to stamp it out
oh okay I didn't know if he broke up
with her and then started pooping on her
question he was with her and he was
to say that he was you mark
okay this is all hearsay all hearsay
please do not sue us we're doing our to
just super the only facts we know is
Nate made his friends carry his to
make a 10 episode documentary series
about this guy and what his motivations
were how many steps were on the bleacher
leecher the bleacher is that the name
yes and that was actually if you haven't
seen a spot on that was that I think he
would just randomly around the
track I think he did it enough times
that there are probably some different
locations the article said the bleachers
I'm sure he you know maybe it's like a
dog where he has his spot or maybe he's
just willy-nilly like a quarter mile in
three-quarter miles whatever smoking two
cigarettes somebody's a kid because he's
doing this every day someone had to
scoop it up and who was good why aren't
they making 115,000 the poppity scooper
is the true hero that's a great point
[Laughter]
p'tee school is the way to go i want you
to do all right
yesterday we were talking about Tom
Cruise and Mission Impossible and we
asked who should be the next
Ethan Hawke super spy no super spike
my favorite response came from Mike
honey who wrote absolutely me okay thank
you Mike honey
you could be like Mike hunt and join a
YouTube community any point where can we
find him you can find Mike hunched over
you let us know who you think should be
the next ethan hawke in the comments for
next time we're gonna do something else
right now epiphany a moment when you
suddenly become conscious of something
that is very important pro wrestling's
definitely scripted but the move still
heard though hi welcome back to Game
Boys I'm winning this is where we played
Monopoly one turn a day until we finish
or they fire us
today's turn is turned 15 so far I have
12 properties four of which are
mortgaged I have two hundred and thirty
two dollars and no health insurance I
have seven properties and twenty nine
dollars but because of my mortgage I own
98 dollars
let's roll
[Music]
Connecticut Avenue I don't I don't own
that
are you gonna buy it oh I already own it
you're cool
[Music]
go to jail bitch jails over here
see you next time we just need a
supercut of Chris confidently but
incorrectly reading
[Laughter]
[Music]
you